good morning Hank it's Sunday Hank as
you know last week my book Paper Towns
won an Edgar Award an award given out by
the Mystery Writers of America to the
best mystery novels of the year Hank
this means that I am now the proud owner
of a bust of Edgar Allan Poe which begs
a question what could you do with a Poe
bust you could put him on your head what
could you do with a Poe bust you could
dress him up as a sailor no no you can't
actually he's already dressed up as a
sailor what could you do with a Poe bust
you could play him with him oh you just
got Edgar Allan Poe
what could you do with a Poe bust you
could replace your face my Edgar what
lovely puff you have what could you do
with a Poe bust you could make them wear
sunglasses
honestly in terms of face to sunglasses
ratio Edgar looks more normal right now
than your average Olsen twin what could
you do with a Poe bust you could play
dress-up with a bust of Edgar Allan Poe
what could you do with a Poe bust you
can put it on your shoulder and see if
it'll say Nevermore Nevermore oh wow it
talks Edgar Allan Poe you have a funny
voice what could you do with a Poe bust
you could waterboard him I'm gonna ask
you one last time Edgar what does the
raven symbolize oh you're not gonna talk
you're not gonna talk now you're gonna
talk what could you do with a Poe bust
you can use a Poe bust as fitness
equipment what could you do with a Poe
bust he could be your garden gnome what
could you do with a Poe bust actually I
think I'll just keep him on the mantel
on PS Australian nerdfighters look in
the sidebar for some information about
upcoming events with John